- Did she sign you up
to do a Shrek Airbnb?
- Yeah, she did.
- Because I saw this footage
and it's incredible.
- Most of the great and
interesting things in my life
is because of Rita,
I'd say nowadays.
- She's very random.
I love it.
- She is, yeah.
Yeah, an article came out that Airbnb
had made this Shrek
replica of Shrek's house.
- [Kelly] Sure.
- In the middle of Scotland,
like way out in the middle of nowhere.
- Sure.
- And, yeah.
- You look so creepy in this picture.
- And listen, everyone would
think that we had a photo,
you know, camera crew and stuff.
That was just us two driving
to the middle of nowhere.
She painted herself green.
She revealed she had
brought these costumes
and that we were getting content.
- Oh my gosh.
And you were like, alright.
- I was like, "I didn't
realize this romantic trip
"was about content."
- I just love picturing being romantic
looking like those characters.
- [Taika] Being romantic.
- Yeah.
'Cause that would be really hard
for me to, yeah, to ignore.
- Yeah, and our accents
were pretty terrible.
- Oh no, we have your accent accents.
Let's hear your Shrek accents.
Here we go, we got some footage.
- Hi, who's this?
Fiona, I told you I don't like visitors.
- Oh, don't mind him.
Oh, we all grown pants.
He's just an ogre, he means no harm.
- I sure don't need ya
tellin' any that, woman.
(audience clapping)
Yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
- I'd say my accent is better.
My accent's better than hers, surely.
- I am just saying,
I'm gonna say I can't get
away from the fact that y'all,
like, I really hope you
made out in those costumes.
- There was no, there's no way I could
with a big rubber mask on.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- But this I did, we did that
and we like sat there in
these ridiculous outfits
eating dinner in Shrek's house.
- You got a good one.
- And then after,
she washed the painter off her face.
Okay, well we did that, now what?
- Oh my God.
- Left.
- But how funny is that?
I just love the randomness of,
what a fun relationship.
- [Taika] Yeah.
- Couple goals, I like it.